lot of those government questionnaires  if I'm filling it out for my son oh  right it'll be like race there's only  like two white Hispanic or white  non-hispanic and I guess he is Hispanic  his mom's Mexican so I click that and  then it goes to ethnicity Asian I think  that's true  Asian Hispanic person on the other end  the guy's like what kind of freak is  this no dude there's a guy in the office  [Music]  hey Greg get in here give me the Braves  over here just like I've never seen such  a human before Oh my God he's my next I  clicked all the bubbles out of five you  look at it you're like this person  doesn't make sense at all I was just  like yeah so yeah hold on holy [ __ ]  blows the chips out of his head  I love the guy buying a computer doing a  spin tank